Archimedes was born about 2,300 years ago,
and he made important contributions in math, physics, engineering, and astronomy.
In physics, Archimedes was the first to explain the principle of the lever,
which we will be talking about quite a bit in the third unit.
He invented an ingenious device known as the Archimedes screw,
which can be used to move water from low places to high.
Many of his inventions were actually used to defend Syracuse,
which in his day was frequently attacked.
He created catapults and ballistas, which could fire projectiles huge distances
when enemy ships attacked.
He's even rumored to have constructed a heat ray,
which used mirrors on the bluffs of Syracuse to focus the sun's rays on an attacking ship.
In math, Archimedes was able to calculate the area under a parabola.
This is a shape that we'll be using extensively in the next unit.
He defined the Archimedes spiral, which you can learn more about
in one of the challenge homework problems in this unit,
but the discovery that he was most proud of was his proof that a sphere inscribed in a cylinder
has exactly 2/3 the volume and the surface area of the cylinder.